muy buenas noches pues lo cierto es que
yo vayan a participado en un acto de
campaña aquí cerca de atlanta donde ha
dicho la necesidad de que hayan unos
senadores leales también ha respaldado
ese mensaje del partido demócrata
diciendo que las actuaciones de donald
trump en esos audios evidencian pues un
claro ataque a la democracia y que
donald trump hizo un abuso de poder en
toda regla por su parte el presidente de
donald trump llegará en menos de tres
horas a un aeropuerto cercano a atlanta
para participar en otro evento de
campaña para apoyar a los candidatos
republicanos al senado aquí en georgia
un estado que se ha convertido en el
centro de atención de todo el país
porque aquí se va a decidir la mayoría
del senado hablemos de la importancia
del resultado de estas elecciones para
la presidencia de bailén antón
qué pasa si los republicanos consiguen
retener el control del senado y qué pasa
si son los demócratas los que obtienen
los dos escaños y así lograron un empate
en la cámara alta
si ese mensaje es el que se ha estado
repitiendo a lo largo de toda esta
campaña electoral y es que si los
republicanos
vuelven a ganar a revalidar el liderazgo
en la cámara alta muy probablemente se
bloqueen en todos los proyectos de ley y
propuestas que lleguen tanto de la
cámara de representantes como de la
casablanca eso podría entorpecer por
ejemplo que medidas como el proyecto
migratorio o
el financiero contra el coronavirus pues
se vea bloqueado por el senado eso es lo
que están repitiendo una y otra vez
desde aquí desde georgia sobre todo la
campaña demócrata que se está fijando en
las minorías y especialmente en los
latinos que no salieron a votar en el
mes de noviembre porque bueno ahora
después de todo lo que ha pasado y más
ahora con los escándalos de los audios
consideran que van a haber muchísimos
más
votos de hispanos que van a querer que
su voz se escuche en las urnas sin
embargo aquí varios expertos ya dan por
hecho que mañana no se van a conocer los
resultados electorales principalmente
porque ya han votado tres millones de
personas de manera anticipada y esos
votos van a ser los últimos en ser
contados gracias a santo nivel si
seguiremos pendientes contigo con
nuestro enviado especial a atlanta